five do's and don'ts for marketing your
film five do's and dont's do collect
email addresses do have brand
consistency do create a trailer do talk
to everybody about your movie and make
sure that they remember it and do love
the word marketing start to love it
because it's essential don't be rude
I'm trying to thank you some don'ts but
don't don't be overly salesy I can't
come up with any more don'ts just just
do the do's and just yeah and keep
adding that remember marketing is a
conversation marketing is about saying
something interesting that people
remember that they want to tell their
friends about it's a story it's a
narrative so do continue the narrative
you